laurent misserey vous avez gagné vous
dans 7 essart et william ont d'ailleurs
merci bon mauvais souvenir très bon on a
extrait de sa danse torse au muba
j'aimerais qu'on écoute votre invité
s'il vous plaît comment est-ce que vous
approchez d'ailleurs ben on m'a appelé
juste pour une rencontre en fait j'avais
une interview / / avec télé 7 jours ou
parler de l'émission et on m'a appelé
juste pour un rendez vous mais on
m'avait dit que ça n'engage à rien et
puis et puis j'ai fait le casting et
puis voilà on m'a rappelé et il vous
aurait demandé de danser
non non on entend le pour le casting est
obligé de faire un casting pour eux et
bien sûr donc là on a fait on a fini à
dire que j'ai le père si l'on fait un
casting avec lang n'a vu danser avant
avant de le prendre c'est pas qui a fait
le question mais il avait des problèmes
de vision alors qu'il n'avait pas de
problème pour trouver des gens lamanage
donc ils ont des problèmes pour trouver
des gens là je peux vous dire les voulu
sauter dessus tout maisons des gens
parce que papa pardon mais là j'ai
vraiment des infos ces matériels oui
mais tu veux une info où tu veux un truc
que je vais là c'est bon allez
[Applaudissements]
la foule ne sais pas mais je pense que
ce monsieur ne vous aime pas beaucoup
il s'appelle isabelle oui on vous dit
non mais la mer morte après un show ya
incohérent est-ce que d'habitude voix
ans et comprennent des gens cassage déjà
danser et vous dit julien lepers avis
sont bientôt les autres matches
attendait entre encore savoir ne pas
savoir danser et remplit les différences
lui ferait le plus intéressant et le
projet